to be able to code some deep learning
model in Karis using a tensor flow as a
back-end and to implement the transfer
learning curves which I added at the end
because I think is very practical for
you to know that this is out there and
not for you to try to reinvent the wheel
so I think we are more or less ok but
it's gonna go this way so each of them
is one of the notebooks so just as a
curiosity who already knows what deep
learning is oh ok so yeah thank you
now and who has already programmed some
some something ok so yeah you were just
here around the thing in the street and
I came in ok good but maybe I can give
you some extra some extra things that
you can learn and of course you can
always ask sort of an advanced question
and I will try to answer it
okay so for those of you that don't know
deep learning or I also see sometimes
people that don't know deep learning but
don't know sort of the history of it
where to come from who are the pioneers
and I think that's also very important
to see who to follow what blocks maybe
to search and stuff so that's the idea
of deep learning comes from the the
artificial neural nor which came from
really 1940s or 1950s already and then
it has been revolution in the last I
will say two decades with the
introduction especially well that would
be three decades in 1986 of
backpropagation by Geoffrey Hinton so I
will say he's the father of deep
learning if you don't know you should
search him because he's everywhere so I
will say something like this will be
more of the one in black will be one of
the most important so I think especially
this one in 1986 the introduction of bop
propagation and then now you can train
these a neural networks there are other
ways to train them but this one really
improved the performance and that's one
show especially in 2012 that's that's
where I think the break the breakthrough
came in so there's this competition
which is called image Nets so it's open
to the public every year and there's
just me the model and then you get some
accuracy score and when Alex net was
into was introduced it blew away all the
other type of models which were not
based on deep learning and that's where
people started noticing and then
Microsoft Google started grabbing the
heads of these departments and
universities like young laocoon like
your Hinton itself to lead their their
departments in AI in 2014 this is of
course very new but this a sort of a
revolutionary idea what is called
generative adversarial networks I won't
talk about them if you submit a question
and I get enough votes in it I will
address that at the at the end and then
2015 some clear sort of breakthroughs of
okay and you know
human bein actually capabilities and I
will say it became sort of mainstream
and worldwide this 2016 alphago I think
might be sort of a just a news kind of a
click big thing of course the algorithm
is extremely complicated but it really
make a breakthrough for the layman to to
know okay now have to pay attention to
it and especially Korea for example
these the revolutionize the country
because they are very into the game of
of called a yeah and young a cool so he
leads the AI research for Facebook and
was one of the inventors of the
convolutional neural networks and he
said you know this idea for generated
adversarial networks introduced in 2014
is the best idea so far in the last
decade and it is really really thinking
outside the box because it allows us to
do something that we were not able to do
before which is sort of penalize or have
a sense of a loss function for something
that we as humans cannot identify ok so
what is the deep neural network so
basically is a artificial representation
of the way our neurons work right so
they have some connections to want to
each other they have certain current
that flows from one to another and then
they can shut or knots so we have the
concept of layers input/output so sort
of a translation like that so that's a
feed-forward neural network there are
many many types we're gonna see a bit
more and then one description basically
is just translating that into this
artificial neuron where you have where
you have so some inputs that come from
other neurons then you have here some
non-linearity that transforms this input
into some outputs and then this output
basically connects to other ones right
that's that's the basic ideas I think
it's very easy to understand it's
nothing complicated so the components of
it and I think everybody I guess knows
these names by now is that the input
layer
which is basically your features or
whatever you decided that to be it can
be their pixels of an image can be also
can be already features that you you
made with your data then you have the
concept of hidden layers which are the
layers that sort of do the sort of
calculation or their mimic then the
nonlinear function that represents the
relationship between your inputs and the
output that you want to get and then you
have basically the output layer and that
basically is okay I want to let's say do
a classifier of binary I don't know good
or bad or a sentiment classification
something like that
so that will be just one run right but
then if you will have for example a
classification now at different classes
let's say ten okay then there will be
ten runs there and it's it sounds very
easy to say but once you get to it you
need to understand what you want to get
and how to relate that for example if I
tell you okay which which activation
function do you use when you when you
and your output layer for different
categories for ten categories isn't the
same that you use when you do binary no
it's not the same
so which one it is okay and then so it
has some relation so we're gonna see a
bit about that a bit more concrete an
artificial neuron this are more or less
the components so you have certain
weights so that basically mimics the
connections between different neurons
can be strong connections or or not so
strong connections then once they get
here in this case you sum them and then
you apply a non-linearity see these
non-linearity is called the activation
function which the most famous one
nowadays Israel ooh so rectified linear
units and do you also have others like
hyperbolic tangents as well and other
ones okay
so what is the idea about these layers
so the idea is that the layers learn
hierarchical feature representations so
that means if I'm going to recognize the
face for example so I start by
recognizing
shapes like lines and then I start
recognizing maybe circles and then maybe
these circles together capture the eyes
or the ear or the mouth so do you have
certain schematic representation that
sort of they look more like your target
that you want to identify in this case
so there are a bunch a neural networks a
bunch like if you google normally people
will know just a few because those are
the ones that that sort of outperform
everything else but there are a lot of
them in these today we're gonna see
fully connected and convolutional ones
but for example and some other in some
other trainings I also give a recurrent
long short term memory get a recurrent
unit I won't talk about them but again
if you submit a question then I can
maybe say something about two minutes or
something like that there are a lot I
don't know them all I know I know them
by name but not like specifically some
of them are actually quite old okay so
what is the typical flow for
implementing this new deep neural
networks so let's take this example so
in this example we have two inputs we
have the first hidden layer made of
three hidden units then we have
connected to two hidden units and then
we have a single one so this can be some
sort of regression or can be is also
some sort of classification depends on
the function that you put on your output
layer okay so what happens is that so
the input goes and gets multiplied by
these weights right so at the beginning
these weights are randomized and then
they create this sort of the the input
for the first unit of the first hidden
layer okay so and it's represented more
or less by this function that you have
here and then you continue and you
propagate forward so you would do this
for every or every neuron in the network
and you propel it forward until you
reach the end once you reach the end and
you call you have your loss function you
will be able to say okay and this is the
error that I have right this can be the
classification
if you have for example generated
adversarial networks that was completely
different but if you have sort of a
regression that you want to apply that
can also be done but then that would be
maybe r-squared or something like this
so yeah you have your and now comes the
backpropagation which is the 1986 so
that Delta that error now you want to
calculate that error for each of the
neurons in your network why do you want
to do that because then you can
calculate the gradient of that error
which will point you then to the correct
direction that your weight should move
that's basically it so in this case for
example this would be the the error
propagated to the neuron for oh sorry
and the same thing but of course because
there are more connections every time
then it gets a bit more involved right
and you can imagine if it gets this gets
really a wide for example and deep this
basically gets really really sort of
complicated in the sense of how the
dependencies are throughout the network
and then you go all the way back and
then you calculate the derivative or the
gradients in this case for that a
specific weight and then basically you
apply what we all know from linear
regression for example this basically
the optimization rule you have you have
your derivative over your last function
that you propagated all the way back so
for that a specific neuron and you
basically then add certain coefficient
that will be the learning rate we all
know that from linear regression and
then you basically adapt your weight and
that's it and then you do it for each
one okay so now if you see here there is
a lot of dependencies right because the
penalisation of the weight for let's say
that connect to neuron one will depend
on the other weights for example from
from neuron four or four nine five yeah
so far so good so how do we actually
calculate this so actually we calculate
this by using the what is called the
chain rule which is sort of a base
the way to calculate derivatives are
dependent on other another functions and
there are different ways to do this one
of the ways is to do this this numerical
approximation that if everybody took a
bit of calculus I guess that was the
first equation and you were like what
what is this H and why does it limit to
zero but anyway so that's one way which
is really expensive and it's also prone
to error because what I just said so
normally you will see a limit their
limit I forgot it so sorry for that for
those mathematicians here so limit to
have h going to zero but then it's a
computer right so what does it mean what
does it mean does H Lin just you watch
the actual value I'm gonna put there
that's it it turns difficult and I've
done it myself during my PhD and yeah
you don't want to do that okay so
instead of that you have what is causing
symbolic differentiation symbolic
differentiation means that you have the
actual function that is the derivative
so for example if my function is I don't
know X for example I don't go and do X
plus h sorry X minus X minus H divided
by H instead of say well is one so you
declare it somewhere else that the
derivative of that function is 1 so it's
symbolic so what that allows what that
allows us to do is that we don't need to
do this numerical approximation and it's
much faster so that's why for example
tensorflow does so if you go into the
tensor flow source code every layer that
you're gonna find their activation
function that derivative is defined you
are gonna find it because it uses this
because if not it will take forever and
it's also prone to error for what I just
said so there are some what I will say
but maybe somebody that is more expert
than me will say no it's because of this
or that I think there's some sort of
conventions so for example when you have
the relu the derivative if you know that
relu the relu looks like this goes like
this until 0 and then it goes like that
ok
so what's the problem with the
derivative of that exactly so right so
okay now you okay how do you do it right
so if you go to the tensorflow code
there's an if
of course right so to my to my physics
is mathematical background is like but
it is and it's a convention you can see
it there okay so so you can find it and
that's why it's a bit fast much faster
than you would do numerical computation
and the issue is that if you evaluate
the derivative from zero you have to you
have to make a choice so they make a
choice
apparently not spurn probably like I
said probably someone that actually
implemented this will will let you know
more you can ask them in github of
course maybe there's already wonder but
no apparently is not an issue and it's
not the only one it's not the only
function that does that okay so how
these back propagation so everybody good
with the bad procreation more or less
you get it back you propagate your
errors they calculate the derivative and
then you move okay so how does these
back propagation and actually works so
first of all like I said well you need
to define these errors right so then for
that you can define your lot you have to
define your last function so then you
can differentiate the last function
because if not how do you know what the
error is if you haven't defined
basically okay you know it's R squared
or is a binary curse and sorry I kept
the particles across entropy or binary
whatever you want so that's the first
thing and there are a bunch in already
in chaos then for that and then the next
thing is you're gonna have to define
your optimizer how am I going to run the
gradient descent right from linear
regression we know is too caste great in
the sense or great in the scent by
itself right great descent if we know
yeah it's taking basically all the data
and you do once optimum once the
optimization step for all the data
stochastic gradient descent
says okay we're gonna use batches right
and then for each of the batch I do a
step and I move right that's why it's a
bit more sick sagging if you if you see
a Delos curve so but there are other
ones so we have several like stochastic
rate descent with momentum other grad
rmsprop that works well especially for
recurrent neural networks atom which I
will say it's more or less the de facto
right now to use that things also to the
faulting cares so all of these I won't
go specifically because we have a little
time but all of these is just is their
stochastic you Granger sends the same
rule but it adds a bit of momentum to
the search so when you do a stochastic
gradient descent or Gary in the sense
what you actually are doing you have a
surface and you're trying to find the
minimum of that surface and what is
doing is moving and it's checking is
this lower than that and then it moves
this is lower than the other one and
then it moves to that point and stuff
like that right
it continues okay so but what this what
this actually potentially can can do to
you
is that you get stuck right around a
valley so when you add a momentum to it
it's more like searching with a bicycle
so you have a downhill you're going with
your bicycle and you find sort of the
valley and you continue a bit more and
no no it still goes up okay then I'll go
back but maybe it goes it has the
momentum enough to cross this this local
minimum and then it finds maybe the
other one yeah all of these bare are
under this principle just the way they
implement momentum that's the thing that
is different good so okay so and the
only words I know okay so this is a some
example of that so for example you can
see especially a thing in the picture on
your right you can see the difference
right and that those those surfaces are
special surfaces that are made to tests
this sort of minimization of
functions even before I knew deep
learning I knew this the other one which
is we call it in Mexico the horse settle
says because it has this this yeah of
course that's not how we call it in
Spanish but yeah that's that's that's
basically the translation last yeah a
caballo I think it's okay so so you see
the difference right so you can get
stuck and especially for surfaces that
are very complicated that's a big issue
because you're gonna have a lot of bumps
so a surface where you have I don't know
20 layers and then each of the layer has
30 units so that means I don't know
you're gonna have and yet then you have
some maybe convolutions maybe you end up
with 3000 weights so that means 3,000
dimensions on this surface is very proud
to have local minima yeah so it's very
important so in my opinion never use a
stochastic gradient descent I think I've
also made the ticketing carriage that
they should remove it or something now
okay so okay so that's brainless how you
train them so I also I think this is a
very important slide especially for
people coming because say you see and
they get impressed and you go to these
starts and these guys using deep
learning why am I not using it as well
and it's not for everything at least in
my experience okay so the data types we
can separate them in structure data in
structured data for structured data you
will normally use handcraft feature
engineering right so and normally the
best algorithms that perform are
boosting algorithms ok or in symbols
methods okay if you don't know what that
is you can you can search it also add
the link here where you can have a read
it's a bit more cut more complete and
when you use deep learning when you have
unstructured data yeah so you when you
cannot come up with what are the
features of this maybe it's a signal
from a from a heartbeat or something
like that or maybe yeah like an image of
course that's the obvious case
texts as well right how do you define
the parts of a text how do you find the
actual meaning of a certain word when
he's sarcastic or nuts right that's
incredibly difficult so this is for this
is for these cases okay so I will say in
a general way and especially if you're
just starting images texts and signals
and you can you can see this link which
is quite a nice explanation and about
the data so a good performance can be
achieved normally like in a general rule
of thumb with 5000 labels sorry labeled
data for in this case supervised
learning for unsupervised we don't even
talk about that because now you're
talking about reinforcement learning and
those actually have to happen in a fake
environment that you can repeat as many
times as possible and now you're talking
about billions of experiments so I'm
talking and supervised learning here
okay and for really to get into human
performance we're talking now about
millions okay now I will say this is
true if you start from scratch this is
not true if you use transfer learning
okay we're gonna go a bit what that is
the recommended literature that I'll
definitely go have a read I don't think
is that heavy in in math but it does
have some linear algebra in it but yeah
that's that's the book I recommend you
to buy and some trainings of course my
trains anyway so there is a way that
that's the rest week and I think yeah so
next that made 29 so prison and so you
can just take a look okay so we're going
to talk now about deep learning tools
questions not so far good
know how we're doing in time but that's
it yeah I forgot about that should put
her here okay this is a short one so
deep learning tools so deep learning
tools there are several there are many
they're more than this you have also
cafe MX net etc but if you are going to
start choose one of these
caris or PI torch well tensorflow as
well but then you can use carrots with
tensorflow at the backend tensorflow is
sort of the what is it what is the
phrase nails and bolts something like
that if you actually want to build that
for something from scratch so for
example the other day I was researching
some type new or not researching but I'd
I tried to build something to translate
a research or idea into a neural network
and of course it's not implemented so I
had to use tensor flow for example right
but for any other sort of standard use
cases I will say go to chaos Oh pi torch
okay in for today we're gonna touch on
cars so why are we going to touch and
Karis basically one of these one of
these explanations basically because
it's very popular and it's of course
that's like okay you're all going in the
popularity trance right now but that
means also there is a big community
behind it so there are issues you can
search there are gonna be less box of
course because it's open source or every
open source of course and also not on
persona has bugs but so there's a large
community and especially recently has
taking a has taken a nice boom with the
tensorflow background in the backend so
basically as we're gonna do we're gonna
do scare us with a tensorflow back-end
you could also use torch for example so
we're using also like the top two right
so also this is basically the community
contributors Forks issues and activity
right and if you start using it don't be
afraid of submitting issues huh like if
you check issue some issues are like
really a question maybe that the the guy
that made it didn't thought about it and
you can help the community
by doing that so visualization about
this what I like this is the tensile
adjust comes with it right so it has a
tensor board where you can just see how
your models are training you actually
can see it real time how the models are
training the last curve house is
performing so you could stop it for
example if these stakes I don't know
a couple of days or something like that
you can also compare with other runs
that you have made and also has I don't
know if you guys know what word
embeddings is but it also has a
visualizations for this so it's very
complete from pi touch sides you have
visiting which I haven't used but it's
far far more customizable but of course
comes with a penalty that world you have
to do it okay so in general in general
one of the things that I will say is
that why do I sort of I think PI Touch
is gaining a lot of popularity yesterday
I was in a deep learning meetup by here
in Amsterdam and they were using a PI
touch for example there was a in the
university so research but for me is
like tensorflow I mean the people that
is behind there's a flow I mean it's
Google I mean you know they're releasing
these things like crazy since they took
over right now I mean it was what 1.4 I
think I don't know a year and a half ago
now I think they are already 1.7 or
something like this they're releasing
like crazy and and it's getting better
and better and better and you're gonna
see for example for the choice
especially for the transfer learning
case how easy it is to have these tensor
flow in the backend it's just it just it
will just work of course there's also
some some issues like everything okay so
this is gonna be the first exercise I
think this is what you were waiting for
so so of course if you already had
Karras enters the flow installed you are
gonna be able to run this if you didn't
then it means that there's an
environment file there on the repo and
using anaconda
you basically will have to run the
command sorry
Conda and conduct and create - f
environment environment llamo so that's
a bit maybe a mouthful but basically so
let's say for example
no.not projects you cannot see that yeah
so there's the environment file you can
see there right now you would do
something like click on the 3/8 and as
if not
so if you don't have experience with
with anaconda maybe ask your buddy in
the side I can also help you as well and
so I'm gonna I'm gonna leave you guys to
work on it let me see what what what I
wrote in the schedule hopefully we're in
time and for others please raise your
hand people that don't have laptops and
questions it can be about anything
what is the actual impact where have you
seen it used where have you not seen use
what are you gonna talk on San Francisco
what is these other other L STM's
recurrent networks so I can talk to
while other people is working on it so
let's check the issues first yeah and
and I see some faces that I know you
know how to create a virtual environment
so help the others I know I know you let
me write it down but let's see let's see
if there are some issues all right
well nothing okay so no questions good
Oh first run detail first so you can see
actually like nice images because if not
you're gonna get any like in your face
so basically this notebook is very basic
so if you already like if you take it
like really quick just go to the next
notebook you have the link at the bottom
of the of the other notebook but this
basically will try to teach you how to
build a model how do you add these
so-called layers right so try to try to
run it
if you cannot install and you're sick of
it because it just doesn't work and you
have because you have a Windows computer
or something like this which is normally
normally the reason so you have some
links here where you can where you can
read maybe you read something about it
and then you ask me a question and you
have all other links about the layers
yes so for carrots are you going to see
in that notebook once you create a my
model you need to compile the model so
you cannot sort of change it on the sort
of on the fly why torture allows you to
do this yeah so fighters are so in a
sense you can a layer train then add
another layer train without this compile
compilation
yeah
so the lair is a collection of neurons
which which which are so if you have if
so this this will be a layer this this
yeah yeah so you can have you can have
for example this is called
somebody knows what these layers are
called yourself so yeah fully connect
the layers yeah so then you can have for
example a drop out layer which is said
and then I will need to explain what
drop out this but basically you put sort
of a egg I will say a gate which
randomly throws away some of the some of
the lines so for example that's because
you want to it's for the reason of
overfitting so you don't want so for
example this one is learning something
very very specific and it comes from
certain power at the image now let's say
the image change a bit and this doesn't
fire anymore so it's really it's
overfitting on that particular image so
you want to sort of throw a weight
sometimes such that that other neurons
learn to compensate so that's that's an
example of a that's a dropout layer okay
then you have for example or all
activations or also layers you can see
them there also there then you have for
example an LS TM layer so on I won't
explain what lsdm but you can basically
have your lsdm layer and there's a whole
machinery going on and you say well
after my listing layer I want to connect
the outputs to so a fully connected one
for example I don't know you can say one
more that is their convolutional for
example right you have a conf yeah so
for example you have your image we're
gonna use that right and now it comes
into a convolutional layer so you just
throw it in like okay this will do just
the convolution
and this sort of and then you say okay I
want another convolution and then maybe
you are wonderfully connected
yeah so it sort of Heights this
machinery of each of the not the same in
the sense the how this works right but
in the sense that their stack but but if
I if I would for example if I say okay
what is in here yeah so these are
recurrent for example this is actually
an extended what they connect to
themselves in previous previous step so
it that's what I like a bit about carers
so you know the theory you know how they
work and implementing it this yeah yeah
but this is also sort of I will say a
bit of a problem right no because people
just throw layers and it it doesn't
really know why right so I think I'm not
sure but maybe there's an example here
yeah I think I have an example where it
is gonna be something weird there
validation is gonna have a higher score
than the training set yeah so let's say
you do you throw these layers right you
because you read it somewhere and you
find this and then you're like okay and
then you show it to me and I ask and I
ask you what why why is this yeah so
it's because of how they're one of the
behavior of the layers but so I will say
that I like yours because makes the
implementation easier I do you don't so
data scientist is I think one of the I
think by now I hate computers right yeah
because the problem is our computer that
problems are not a theory but anyway so
so Karis makes it very easy for you so
if you know the theory behind it a bit
it's just throwing it around so for
example one of the things I think I
asked during the notebook
you can see the summary of the model
let's let's let's let's let me show you
that
for example let's just start with this I
mean even the simplest I tried to add a
layer and it doesn't work why why it
doesn't work and you have to think about
the concept well because just the
concept of it it doesn't know what
inputs is gonna get so just the concept
of it this doesn't make sense so you can
define your own input layer but then
below I do it caris that's it for you
you just add oh I expect this
I expect this amount of dimensions and
Chara's will do it for you but you do
need to know it because you let's say
you you you hit this error right the
first layer and a sequential model must
get an input shape or batch batch input
shape arguments yeah sure so you add it
and why what value should be right so
it's because it's is the amount of
inputs that you you're gonna get in this
case we saw this this or two so these
are the inputs so if you see the first
hidden layer here you have input two but
the amount of units it's three so I'm
creating this sort of interface yeah so
it makes it easy for you you could also
define one by one but for the input is
not not necessarily you can also for
example yeah for example this this
question below that's when I catch
sometimes that's sort of my first
question sometimes also for some
interview or something when they say oh
I know deep learning ah good good so
okay so then I asked them I just
disabled where did why are there nine
parameters
okay so yeah and how does hold it does
come up to two nine so yeah you're
you're in the correct path that so you
have these two connections right that's
already here what do i I like to draw I
guess so you have these two right and
three so how many weights are there six
so why are there nine yeah somebody said
it the biases and they're you know yeah
so actually each of these is more or
less like a logistic unit right these
weights times the features plus a bias
that's where they come from
okay now when you would implement a
convolutional there are also parameters
and also the question i think you get to
understand when you when you throw a
layer and then you see the parameters
you're able to try to understand okay
why are these some on the parameters
because you do need to know what's
happening in order to do that you could
you could just don't care as well but I
would think you would like to care but
that depends yeah so about this these
sort of layers they are they're all
there yes they are all there and there
for you to access and for example one of
the difficulties that I see
sometimes when people try to implement
convolutional layers is the input/output
the dimensions because you need to
define the dimensions it will tell you I
this but I received this and that's a
bit I will say I will think a bit more
tricky for people that are just starting
up and that's because how does the
actual convolution works right so you
can try it I think it's the one it's me
I think it's one of the exercises later
I think but you're probably gonna hit
this problem I even hit it now and as oh
yes I forgot this other other dimension
but so that I've got the parameter so of
is the same thing they're there for you
they have your back more questions okay
so what we're seeing right now like I
mentioned here on the top this is the
sequential API caris has two types of
api's that I know of
let's say look at sequential and
functional API the sequential LPI
is the easiest it sequentially SPEA api
is the one that yeah it sequentially now
the one that is one after the other
okay there is no sort of coming back or
branching and then reconnecting well so
so for most of the no not yeah of course
for most yeah for most of the use cases
sequential api is enough given that you
know what the layers are actually doing
like like you said so for example but if
you want to build for example
let's say you want to build this can you
build it with a sequential API of course
not
it's not possible right so you need to
do the function on this case is this
actually a model we we use for what a
colleague II used and built for
detecting anomalies in the heart from
MRI scans for a project so you cannot
write you have to use sequential you
sorry you have to use a functional right
but we're gonna stick with the basic
question for today yeah yeah so that's
research and there's the main knowledge
and just trying and there are already
some sort of older architectures where
they do something similar so they sort
of build on each other right so for
example if I show you let me see
actually it's a good time to see who
should be in the next one okay anyway so
if I show you this for example
oh I don't have it okay
maybe it was loading like yeah I was
loading okay if I show you this one for
example right
that's Inception v3 I was made by Google
2015 I think at least the paper okay so
if you see yeah
they built on top of each other so these
for example this architecture that you
see more or less than repeats was
already before somebody introduced it
and this has to do with convolutional
and and the pulling from layers butts
and then they say okay why don't we
start them together right and then you
see this tail here that looks like that
this is also question I asked sometimes
what is this because everybody talks
about this what is this I guess it is
there it is there what why there's
actually this is not complete sometimes
it goes there's there's there are more
in the back and then it's great right
why why would i have two outputs because
actually this is this is soft max so
soft max this one once you want to make
the classification and it's in both
places why why would they want to output
the output once we go to the transfer
learning we I'll answer the question
okay let's see I'll help you out a bit
so the different activation functions
like I said the softmax they're Israel
ooh that somebody knows now that because
I started someone had experience why is
there for example the hyperbolic tangent
not preferred over the rail ooh or what
is the problem with a hyperbolic tangent
know how nice yeah it is because that so
so they saw the hyperbolic tangent has
these these sort of look right so it's
flat here and it's flat here so what's
the problem with that yeah this guy you
should talk to a chief scientist that
we're hiring so this is yeah because the
derivative is zero so it means that when
you remember you propagate back and you
calculate the derivative and let's say
for some reason your input goes into
these parts what what is the value that
is going to multiply by zero so what is
gonna be the propagation back zero is it
gonna learn anything no and then your
model is stuck that's called the
vanishing gradient problem okay
it has two to two sources one is this
one is this there are other sources and
the other source is actually a soft bite
white but I just show you about having
the extra branch by anyway so this one
here yeah that's okay but the problem is
that if you if they go sort of say in
this sense you don't want them but the
thing is here they're in both sides and
that's that's sort of the the problem
because yeah that's the other issue so
when you have a matrix right and you're
multiplying values let's say these
values are lower than one right so
they're gonna go to zero basically right
but if they're very big or they're
bigger than one want to multiply they're
gonna end up in this area
right now so they're gonna end up in
this in here which this does not have
the problem that's the other that when I
said the two sources one is the source
is the activation function and the other
source is the multiplication because in
system so recursive there's going to be
a lot of sort of multiplication of
weights to get to that one so if the
weights are lower than one they're going
to tend to zero and they're going to
banish the same way that this makes it
vanish so that's the other source or
they can be bigger than one and then
they're going to explode so they're do
you have two problems the vanishing
gradient problem and the exploding
gradient problem and the so that's why
yeah yeah but then yes yes yes
so that's when you have what is called
leaky relu you can say do you look at
your activation functions no leaky relu
so it defines it defines sort of an
angle in here there are there are many
ways to deal with that but the result
for example takes away those those zero
tails but good questions okay so this is
what I said about a compiler remember
who asked about the difference between
PI torch and right so it compiles so I
say you know use the optimizer i Adam
here's what you need to know sort of
okay what are the activation functions
how do they work why why is it binary
Concentra P right depends on what you're
going to calculate so for the next
example for example we're going to use I
think cross-entropy
which is for more than one class and if
you really want to get into the details
then you do the config which is helpful
as well and notice this one notice this
primer trainable so it has enough to
turn that wait to freeze the weight so
say you know I
like this I like this value of my weight
right now so I want to freeze them I
don't want to optimize these weights so
that's basically what we're going to do
in the transfer learning okay so in here
I created these data set which is not
linearly separable okay so basically I
create the typical test set now
also by default caris comes with what is
called callbacks if some one of you is
already familiar with what a callback is
but basically is that at certain point
in time during the training it's gonna
call a function and then it's gonna do
something with that so Karis already has
for example four for doing the tensor
board already has it for it because you
need to save it into some locks how your
training is going so Karis already has
that so you send it as a callback and
it's gonna sort of save the accuracy
that is having during training time in
that lock and then tensor board is just
gonna pick it up in real time and it's
going to update the figure that's that's
how it works but you can say any type of
callback so this I created my own
callback you can see it in the in the
utils in the UTS module in here so how
it looks should be somewhere there so
it's this one so now it's yours you can
use it no problemo
and you add it as a callback okay now if
you see you once you compile you use the
model fit alright very easy and then you
just send the training data the number
of epochs so the number of epochs is the
number of times you're gonna go through
their whole data set so for example
let's say you're not you're not
shuffling your data set when you choose
a batch let's just say you separate in
five batches so you say ok I'm gonna say
I have I don't know a thousand
observations and I may
make batches of 200 okay so then I have
five batches and each five batch that's
an epoch yep because you're gonna see
this in the in the when you read stuff
right so an epoch is not it's not each
optimization time it's optimization step
is once you go through the whole data
set so in this case I have a batch size
of 100 I don't remember how many
observations ahead and I'm running at
any box okay if you see also out of art
of just very simply you have validation
split so on training time is gonna
separate in a validation so it's gonna
sort of optimize for certain part of
your data set and for the other one is
Jana is gonna calculate whatever score
you you want to calculate in this case
is accuracy so that's why if I put
berbils one in here for example all
right you can see this validation stuff
so if I wouldn't add that right I don't
have it it uses the whole data set to
Train yeah
that's why all right so there you see it
in this case and that doesn't do
anything but I don't know why but anyway
so okay so then you have the curves let
me just close
okay start improving but this is this
better okay so you're gonna have these
curves which are the basically learning
curves so in this case I'm just gonna
write okay so in this case if you see
now I define normally you will define
the model like this like just in one in
one go so before I did it in certain
different cells just to sort of take you
through it but normally you will do it
like this
okay so also these curves that are here
are are made by this function I made so
this also yours you can use it and then
you have what is called these the
learning curves so this in this case is
the accuracy so how many times I'm
guessing the class correctly right and
then you see the curve for validation
set and training set during training
time okay so and then the loss right so
in this case we said I think binary
entropy cross entropy and we have the
loss function here how is it behaving so
when I see this right so it's not
flattening out so it's it appears that
still it's going to go down so you
probably need more epochs in this case
right you also might see something maybe
maybe we can see it here you are but
then I'm gonna show you the answer okay
that's fine okay so now what I did is
not really expected so sometimes you
might see really sick SAG function sorry
curve so something that it is going down
for example I don't know if it's gonna
happen with this because the data set is
sort of pretty prepared but yeah also
because of the amount of classes there
not many you might see something for
example let's say the accuracy that
looks maybe like this
now you might see something like that so
any idea what this might be the problem
this is now let's say this is accuracy
so this normally is because remember the
weights get updated every on every batch
so it means that each of these points is
what happened for every batch so it
means your batches are too small right
so it is moving in the correct way but
because your batches are too small
they're not capturing the actual
representation of your data so in
average is moving to a correct position
but it is sort of taking these these
steps where you're not really optimizing
for the data itself but just this this
Bachelor is too small yeah so you might
see this I've seen this several times so
that means just increase your batch okay
so I think we so so okay so now we have
this this exercise too so maybe some of
you went over it a bit already so I want
you so these are two classes of course
you can separate in some other way but I
just wanted you to do to learn how to
add other type of layers
so what I wanted here is just make an
overkill model so model that is just
extremely big for these two classes and
it's something like that so the idea is
that we're gonna create three hidden
layers we're gonna use batch
normalization we're gonna add dropout
layers and we're gonna use Ray Lu and
also the hyperbolic tangent I don't care
about the accuracy about this it's just
for you to actually make it run okay so
what batch normalization is that's
normalization layer so yet another layer
it's basically you have your sort of
your your input layer or I don't know
something and then you have your another
hidden whatever something like that
right and let's let's put it here for
example let's say you have these
connections
something that is right and then these
sorry the activation of these neurons
right it's going to be multiplied by
these weights and then they're gonna
enter the each of the neurons and then
they're gonna be squashed or by this
nonlinear function it can be rare Lu
which can be the hyperbolic tangent okay
so for example when you use the hyper
hyperbolic tangent like like my friend
here explained this this sort of are a
bit of a problem there's another problem
with but I'll mention in a bit so you
will like the inputs to this to be
around this this area so what what the
Batchelor molestation does it does what
you do
when you in a linear regression when you
scale your features exactly the same
thing it does exactly the same thing but
it does it in the middle of the layers
so if you add a Bachelor molestation
layer in here you basically rescale this
such that for the pencil on the type but
let's say such that it has mean 0 and
variance 1 and then it throws them into
into here such that you do have the data
around that point independent so it's
exactly the same it's per feature so now
the feature is each of these right so
it's exactly same so it's like forget
about that you had that and now you have
sort of let's say this is the input and
you are normal you're sorry scaling your
features yeah so this achieves this
right because you don't want it to be
extreme but what other things why do you
scale linear regression well I said that
was not gonna explain basic stuff of
machine learning but why do you scale it
why do you scale your features again
becoming it doesn't matter normally
normally I will help you out
no ok why I see you know okay so so
normally you scale it
because two reasons if you're using
regularization right
so the regularization penalty the
coefficient is the same for all features
right or not it's just a term which is
like this it's alpha is that right its
weight index index independent so if you
don't scale them this value can be very
big for some features or can be very
small for some others which means the
penalisation term will be huge for
things that are scaled big and for
skills that are there are actually small
then this will be quite small right so
the penalisation term so there's another
reason and the reason is also the last
function and that's what that is related
to the to the neural networks so if you
have let's say you don't do
regularization you still want to scale
them because when you're doing gradient
descent we have what is called the
learning learning rate right we already
know right so you have and we also
introduced it in the equations so you
have your weight I equal to weight plus
1 wait oops wait I write plus some
learning rates in this case I'll call it
off as well times the gradient of your
last function on the weights right okay
so the is this learning rate in the
independent yes right it is the same for
every feature so it can be if this turns
out to be proportional to the value of
the weight of the value of the feature
for example then it means that I'm
taking really big steps and one of the
dimensions are the features and really
small steps for others so I might be
looking in really a nice
recent anisotropy or and I'm not not in
a symmetrical way right and that's when
you see these figures that when you
normalize then you have this loss
function that looks like concentrated
circles I mean everybody has seen that
picture Rolly
so is the same thing for new networks
you want to do that as well because also
your learning rate gets applied in the
same way right there's also a derivative
there okay we're doing a bit short on
time okay I'm just sort of kind of paste
it and explain really quickly please
keep the questions coming if we need if
I need to skip something in that's fine
I'll also be around so can also as I
said so right so these will be more
surrounded a way to to add these layers
right so we have here with the fine
first sequential right we start with
that start fresh
then we add a batter normalization and
we can give it a name you can also put
it without the name then we then we yeah
what is the input shapes like we said
before the input shape is 2 right and
then the first layer has 30 units the
second layer has 10 units and that third
layer has three units right and within
each of those layers I add a batch
normalization what I said before then I
define the activation function if you
see the activation function is no longer
inside the dense layer as before you
remember you see how I gave it in the
dense why is it not there anymore yeah
because the batch normalization right
needs to happen before the activation
function right because of what I just
explained okay and then the drop out
which basically is what I explained
about dropping some of the connections
in order to not over fit
and then you can just run the same I
don't know what was the accuracy of the
other more or less but the batches are
smaller or they all right yeah so this
is the batch size of 100 its microphone
fool compares yes yeah exactly
there's not known yet exactly yeah yeah
yeah you can build also a network
without without activation function they
will just explode but yeah so that was
the story like you go to the initial
papers that's where it starts
just connections just connections like
okay yeah whether you're talking a
decade sir
yeah okay sorry so if you see for
example we added this super overkill and
then I think now I have the same 100 bad
choice of 100 epochs of 10 10 epochs I
think even we could do it with 6 or
something maybe even 5 and see how much
takes and then this should already
outperform the other one that's already
point 8 right and this one is take like
that so okay I have to move to the other
one because we're a bit behind schedule
actually lots so I will try to run a bit
faster it ok ok so we learn what we
learn in the previous notebook so we
learned basically how to add layers to
model right where do I find these layers
where is the documentation where I can
read about it how can you let's say tune
it yourself you can add the activation
function within the layer you can add it
yourself if you want to introduce batch
normalization we saw what button
realization does we saw what dropout
does
you know in a high-level but we did see
that so it's now just about you reading
a bit about more about these layers and
okay this might be useful this not
because you also have you say
convolution for example but then you go
to search for it and then you will find
one dimensional convolution it's there
you I think you saw it in the layers
two-dimensional convolution treatment so
what does it mean what is the difference
between them so that you have to read
about a bit about about that okay so
this is basically in this case digit
task in this case I also have this one
which is actually a pretty hard data set
this one this is the C for ten data set
is there for you just out of the blue
you can just build on top of it it's
pretty difficult it's not an easy data
set but just for sake of showing right
now everything should run if you just
uncomment this one so it's just there
for you okay
so first what do we need to do so we're
gonna prepare the convolutional layer
right so normally you will say okay I'm
having these inputs so I need to have
like a 1 dimensional structure in order
to have my inputs in the case of
convolutional net what you don't write
because you got that's actually what you
want you want to take advantage of these
channels so in this case what I actually
do in here if you see I reshape the data
such that yeah this is this is the
amount of data this is a 28 by 28 image
it has a single channel if you see that
data the data the beginning had no
channel yeah yeah because it's just a
single so by the Fawley would sit like
that but if you want to use this sort of
2d convolution that we're gonna use
later you you have to add this channel
if not it's just not gonna work it's
gonna tell you expected this extra
dimension and it's not there okay so we
also need float float numbers and if you
see what I did is I also rescaled the
pixels to be from 0 to 1 so first
okay so now the idea is I know at it
[Music]
yeah so in this case what I'm doing is
adding sequential starting with a
sequential then I add some batch
formalization the same drop out now you
see the difference now we have this
convolutional layer and it's easy as
that
you just add it to it now the difficulty
a bit is to see about these the kernel
size the number of filters that you have
so the number of filters I won't explain
convolution because it will take us the
whole whole session but it's basically
you go from 3 channels to 32 channels
that's what the filters are so there are
32 different kernels that are gonna be
applied in your convolution if you
didn't understand what kernels us is but
it's basically just so a smaller neural
network that is going to go through your
image yeah so you're gonna have this
sort of not very deep right you have 28
by 28 by 1 channel and then I gonna
convert that in this case by 2 TIPNIS of
32 and what the kernel size is is
basically I'm gonna form sort of a
square of 3 by 3 and then that is going
how am I going to move across my image
that's the convolutional part and what I
use you use an activation also of relu
and border that's how when you hit the
borders of the image so for example if
the size of your kernel does not it's
not a multiple of the size of your image
it needs to make a decision do I stop do
I pad it that's that's basically what
this does so just there are different
options so this one for example just
stops when it hits the border already
create this ok and then you have what is
called max pooling so where the
convolution does it multiplies this
kernel for the image right so let's say
I have a 3 by 3 and it multiplies so I
still I'm still gonna have this 3 by 3
and then what it does it says ok I'm
gonna do something with these 3 by 3
matrix to get a single number and that's
what it's called pulling max pooling
will
I get the maximum value of that can be
average pooling it means it makes an
average depends and then once you finish
that now you now it's gonna start to
connect to the dense layers and it does
need a one-dimensional one so that's why
we have the flattened there so basically
it gets this very deep this Clay's 32
channels and then I guess yeah in some
dimensions I don't know exactly how many
right now maybe seven seven by seven and
then it will basically flatten all that
in a single array and now it's ready for
the dense layer okay and that's when we
add this dense layer and then we see
this already so as a homework or later
you can ask me again for the
convolutional one why why are they three
hundred and twenty questionnaire so try
to figure it out the bits not that you
can bug me and then I will answer you
I know how much these things much so
okay so what we did here you see very
easy
we added layers right we added what we
celebrate The Bachelor Malaysian the
drop out were more importantly with the
convolutional one so the convolutional
one in this case is 2d because it's an
image in 2d
there's also 3d okay because you can
also have known by a race of more
dimensions of course right so that will
be sort of a video okay so if I actually
run this with the difficult datasets I'm
gonna get around I think I get around
this this gate goes very good like
almost 90 percent accuracy but if I run
it with a difficult one maybe I should
leave it running just to show you I get
around 30 percent okay with this
overkill model let me on seconds let's
just do that hopefully it just runs
according to me it should but like a
colleague set
what is it the supposition is the mother
of all fuck-ups there you go
my vocabulary is not that good yeah so I
think what is missing here is this tree
Oh 28 of course now the size of the data
changed the digits are this is what I
mean that the other dimensions always
the problem once you understand it so
that the size of the image is different
for the other datasets so I have to
change it that's basically so before I
have 28 28 one channel now it's 32 32
three channels so I will leave it
running a bit so now let's move to the
most interesting one and also because
we're mostly out of time but I think the
next one you're gonna have fun once you
get to your house you prepare some pasta
or something ok so let's see so we're
gonna use the same data set okay but I'm
gonna talk to you about pre-trained
networks what does a mean a pre-trained
network so a pre-trained network is it's
an a quite complicated network that a
university or Google or somebody else
did already and they put it available so
they wait they are available that's
that's main the main sort of part the
weights after training these very
complicated models are available to you
all these are available to you ok so in
this case we're gonna use I believe
model net why do I choose that basically
because it will not take you that much
downloaded and it's also pretty good
so if you see inception v3 I show you
already it's extremely complex it's
crazy right
this is convolution average pull max
pull concatenation drop pod fully
connected and soft Max and then it's all
that stuff so imagine if you have to
train that on your laptop now it's no
bueno
definitely so so it's great right if we
already have the weights and I'll show
you why so this is mobile net this is
the one we we're going to use and it has
also all this complicated stuff
all right you can go through it if you
want so if you seekers already has a
whole module for it mobile net you can
also replace this for inception if you
want it just inception is a bit heavier
so it will take you a bit more and what
I basically did I said I look at the
type of classes that this learned to
classify so this this model available to
you was the model that it was trained
with the data set of imagenet which is a
thousand classes so it should be able
more or less recognized astonishing
claims so I went into the type of
classes and I choose one you just
download a picture from from Internet so
yeah so I don't worry this this one okay
why did I don't know I my scorpion I
guess I was biased and something but
anyway so for me this image I mean it's
I will say it's not extremely difficult
but the tail especially how it bends
with the background I don't know anyway
so if you see we already have the model
right we'd loaded the model here which
is basically this line mobile networks
image it and then we just basically
adapt this image to the inputs it's just
basically this land they said this is
what is doing and it's gonna predict and
there you go scorpion 99% sure you know
what this means right
this means that you can use it you can
you can come up with a brilliant idea
and it's there already you don't need to
train it of course it has to be one of
these classes okay so now comes the
interesting part right because now
you're bound to the classes that they
train it for but now let's say you have
this brilliant idea I want to detect I
don't know for example I have a problem
with choosing glasses they're all ugly
so you want to say to filter them if
they are good or not and you want to
have somebody that labels and I want to
adapt this to the tech dance how do you
do that thing we're running out of time
what so in this case I didn't do with
the glasses but now I
want to do it for these datasets the
same that I said that we was really
difficult before so what I'm going to do
here is what this is doing is actually
creating a put them in on disk it's
putting the images on my my disk in in a
directory way so because normally this
is the way you're gonna have your data
right in actual files not not by carats
giving you the prepared data set so
that's why I want to make it more
realistic so this is more less so this
basically prepares it for you okay it's
gonna take a bit I think
but let me make sure so now if I go okay
so at least it or III edit it
so you can see yeah so right now it's
creating the training data so basically
you just need to separate your files
like this you you you point to a file
and then each of the classes you put the
name to the directory and then inside
you just put your images it doesn't
matter what name you give to the images
so now what this is going to do okay
just give it a look I'm gonna kill this
one
okay so I have no clue why he's taking
so long
okay I'll stop okay hopefully it did put
already some of them yeah okay so there
is our David Shuster so they are
something inside okay so now what I'm
going to do instead I'm going to load
but I'm going to add this this flag
which says include top false what does
that what does what does do is that it
will give me the whole thing with the
weight but it's not gonna give me this
little part here why because that's the
part that classifies remember we talked
about these hierarchical features so I'm
gonna get the hierarchical teacher
features from everything that was
strained but it's not gonna give me the
other let's see so if you see here five
minutes so you see there's no softmax
anymore right so now what do I do
now what you do and I have to probably
hurry up is adding myself
first what I said right you make those
layers not trainable you freeze them
because well we completed very very
expensive for you to do that so what I
do here is basically add them so I I
basically sent the base model which is
the one we just loaded and then I add a
pulling I add a dense layer to make
these connections and then the final
layer which is a soft Max and basically
I only have three trainable layers
instead of having 22 and 22 which are
quite complicated so now if I do this I
compile it now let's categorical
cross-entropy of course I'm not gonna be
on time on this I think so this will be
a way to get it from the from the file
so this will be say for exam
[Music]
so I want the image to be rescale so
that means is going to be multiplied by
this value and I believe that's all I
need now I'm gonna send this I'm gonna
read from from the file a batch size of
50 and I know that my my model that I
loaded receives 128 by 21 28 so I don't
have to parrot the images this is going
to do it by itself
I believe this oh I see I see
let's see so here what I'm going to say
to it is that pop up up seawall voice
Evo zero okay let's just do this
right so it went in found the ten
classes with forty-eight thousand images
right but they're not loaded in memory
that's very important it's not not
loaded in memory so now when I train it
sorry Vincent let's see yeah just one
more so basically I define you know the
number of epochs that I want and the
steps that I want in the oh yeah and I
need to put this one more and that's it
yeah so now what I'm actually doing it's
getting the data from disk and doing
these changes x 1 to 35 doing the
padding for us already
you can also augment the data by saying
I want to also write eight randomly or
zoom in or zoom out randomly so the
great advantage is this that you read
from disk right you don't have any
memory and you also have the data
augmentation in preparation already for
you this is a and n for lines of code
alright so cares is extremely extremely
easy and I would advise you to increase
maybe the number of epochs and you see
these candies because you're using this
architecture it can get up to eighty
percent with the other what we had what
is it the overkill model it gets to 32
percent or something this is because
we're leveraging in these scales mobile
nets weights
and with that I guess one minute in time
Thanks
[Applause]
you